[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANKUR KOTWAL: Good
afternoon, everybody.
My name is Ankur Kotwal.
And I'm joined--
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm Laurence.
ANKUR KOTWAL: --by
Laurence Moroney.
We're developer advocates
on the Google Maps API team.
And today, we're
going to talk to you
about location intelligence.
And if you've been attending
many of the Google Maps API
sessions at Cloud Next, or
you've been following along
on YouTube, you've probably
heard this term a few times.
I'm going to define it for the
sake of the folks that are new.
But location
intelligence is basically
the idea of taking all
of this location data
and adding context.
Adding that real-time
nature so that you
can infer useful
information out of our APIs
and surface that to your
users in interesting ways.
And in this session, we're
going to really synthesize
that entire narrative
of location intelligence
that we've been talking
about at Cloud Next
and show you how you can walk
up and down a stack of location.
So first I'm going to start
off with a very brief history
lesson, and that's the fact
that it wasn't that long
ago-- just over a decade ago--
that we were using paper maps,
right?
It seems like a very
archaic concept today,
but it wasn't that long ago that
we had this experience, where
if you had to find
your current location,
you'd have to know
the address, and you'd
have to look up this index
of really tiny fonts,
and then find a particular
location, find it on a map.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Anybody got a pen?
ANKUR KOTWAL: [LAUGHS]
And then, once you
wanted to go somewhere, you
had to do the same process
on where to go.
And then the hard
part really started,
which is you had to
navigate your way there.
I haven't navigated my way to
anything for many, many years
now, and that's because
my user behavior,
my behavior has changed.
And I'm sure that's the
same for many of you.
When we moved into
the digital world,
there were a number
of companies that
had that audacious goal
of mapping the world.
And of course, Google
was one of those.
But as our smart phones
got richer and richer,
again, as our user
behaviors changed--
I'm going to give you a simple
example of a user behavior
that changed.
When you were using those maps,
and you needed to move across
to the next edge
of that page, you
used to actually have to
find the page to jump to.
You remember the
map books, right?
You think about our experience
today, we just swipe left--
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm going to
stay in one of the city, right?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yes.
You just now swipe
left or right,
and we have that seamless
connected experience.
That's an example of
a behavior of ours,
a fundamental
behavior that changed,
and our expectations shifted.
And so as we started to
have smart phones that
were well connected, we
started to demand seeing more
of the dynamic world, right?
Having that
information come to us.
So I gave you an
example about navigation
and how hard it was already
to navigate from point A
to point B. That was at least
a static route, a static route.
My accent kicks in
between American
and Australian
between now and then.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I will try
to be the Australian to English
translator, but do bear in mind
that I'm Irish, so kind of--
ANKUR KOTWAL: Translator fail.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
I might be.
So there might be an
impedance mismatch.
ANKUR KOTWAL: But again,
looking at user expectations,
we expect our mapping
apps, whether it's
Google Maps or any
other app, to tell us
when we're going to be
impacted in our journey, right?
When we have a
flight delay, when
there's an accident on the
road or some roadworks,
whatever it may be.
And the way we're trying
to overcome this problem
is by having more
and more sensors,
more connected devices.
And we're starting to see
that with IoT devices, right?
But as we gather
all of this data,
just because you
have data doesn't
mean you have intelligence.
And it's really
machine learning that's
able to process this data
at scale in real time
or near real time, and make it
predictive to add that value,
to add that intelligence.
And that's what I'm
talking about when I talk
about location intelligence.
Now, let's switch from this
to something more about today.
If you think about how we
think about our location,
we think about our location
with maps, maps in our pockets.
We have the whole world
in our pockets, now.
We think of it as maybe
a latitude and longitude
because, depending on the
application you're using,
that's what you need.
You might think of your
location as an address,
or you might think of
your location as a place.
Today, we're on floor three
of the Moscone Center.
Can I get a show of hands?
How many of you know the
address of the Moscone Center?
There is not a single
hand up, just for the--
oh, one over there.
Excellent.
LAURENCE MORONEY: How many know
the latitude and longitude?
[LAUGHTER]
ANKUR KOTWAL: My point
is, as people, we
think of our location in names
that are more familiar to us.
You might know the
address of your house--
I hope you do--
and you obviously probably know
the address of your workplace.
But generally, other sort of
temporary places we visit,
we don't think of our
locations in addresses
or latitude and longitude.
But those latitudes, longitudes,
addresses, and places,
they all have their place when
we use them in an API context.
And navigating across those,
serving our users' needs
across each of those, is really
important and not always easy.
Laurence and I are here
today to show you how you
can do this in an easier way.
I'm going to first also
take a slight diversion
and talk about an example
that you've probably, again,
heard about a few times now in
some of these sessions, which
is ride sharing.
And the reason I want to
talk about ride sharing
is I'm going to go into the
deep technical aspects of it.
If you think about how
we do ride sharing today,
we don't wait on a
sidewalk waiting for a cab
to come for us.
I mean, sometimes we do, but
if you're using the apps,
the experience is
very different.
We pull out the app.
The app automatically
knows our location.
Right?
So it can work out where we need
to be picked up very quickly.
When we choose our destination,
we're not swiping our map
or panning and zooming
all over the place.
We're doing a search
for our destination.
We type in a few
characters, and suddenly it
knows-- you want
the SFO Airport,
or the Intercontinental Hotel.
Whatever the place may be.
And then when you say, hey,
I want to request a cab,
it automatically finds a driver
for you that's closest to you,
and gives you a very
accurate estimate of how long
it's going to take for
that driver to get to you.
Again, we're looking
at changes in behavior,
but think about the
underlying technology
that goes behind this.
Your current location
might be GPS,
or you might be
indoors at the time
that you started
looking for this.
So we have to use some sort
of indoor mapping technology
to find our locations, because
GPS needs line of sight,
and when you're indoors, you
don't have that line of sight.
When we're looking
at our destination,
we have to use a database
that knows about all
of these places in the world.
I'm going to talk about
that database in a minute.
And then of course, there's
the dynamic routing.
As that taxi driver or cab
driver is being sent to you,
it's able to route them in
the quickest possible way
to avoid traffic, to avoid
roadworks, and give you
that estimate, that
very accurate estimate.
So it's really,
really important to be
able to walk across this
stack of understanding
the driver's location and the
user, the passenger's location.
So we're really on the cusp of
this revolution around location
intelligence.
And what it's enabling
us to do is power many,
many use cases in how you
can bring our Google Maps
APIs together.
Location intelligence
is revolutionary.
We just talked about ride
sharing as an example.
A year ago, we
would not have had--
actually, I'm going to
talk about industries
in a second, which
is right here.
A year ago, when we
looked at the industries
that our use cases
were useful, we
wouldn't have included
gaming, right?
Because whilst we had some
location or real-world games,
it hadn't exploded
in as big a way.
There was a talk earlier
today about real world gaming
and how "Pokemon Go" has
really changed the field here.
In the last few months,
since "Pokemon Go" came out,
there have been hundreds
of millions of players
that have gotten involved.
And it's because we
are now able to provide
this kind of location
intelligence to our users.
It's not just about
putting a pin on a map,
it's about knowing
where they can
go, where there are
other players about,
whether the stores
that they are going to
are open right now or not, and
using that in meaningful ways.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And it was
really interesting in how
it was able to bring
innovation to an industry that
wasn't innovating in that way.
Gaming was all about the next
console, the more powerful,
adding more and more power, and
innovation was going in that.
But then suddenly, when
somebody had the realization
to bring geo awareness and
location awareness into it,
we had a whole new
genre of gaming open up.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And
so what we're seeing
is when we use location
intelligence, when
we use maps APIs, we're
affecting existing industries
and helping to optimize
those user experiences,
but we're also creating
new ones as time goes on
or disrupting ones that you
wouldn't have traditionally
thought were relevant.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I
have a favorite one
in the services on demand
space that I just learned
about a couple of weeks ago.
That my daughter is in
university, and being
a student, she
doesn't cook a lot,
so she gets a lot
of takeout food.
But typically, if you
order delivery food,
you have to have a minimum
order, or they won't deliver.
And typically, she's
a five foot girl,
and she doesn't eat a lot, and
she can't spend enough money
to have them deliver it.
So in the university
campus that she's at,
there is this delivery
service that what they do
is that they aggregate
everything together.
So she and four
other girls could
order from five
different restaurants.
And then these
people will do that
and go to the five
different restaurants,
get the food for them,
and deliver it to them.
And then the
restaurant is winning
because they're getting delivery
customers that they normally
wouldn't get because
they had a price barrier.
The kids are winning, so they're
not spending as much money
as they normally would have
had to get something delivered.
And then this
service that came in,
that's able to geolocate
where the kids are,
and then able to use geolocation
to find the restaurants.
And when the kid
does an order, they
can check against the
menu for that restaurant
to see that they are
not being ripped off,
and stuff like that.
And then this whole new service
has grown up almost overnight.
And everybody's winning.
It's really cool.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So
in this session,
we're going to talk about three
ways that we see location.
We're going to talk about
latitude and longitude, which
is traditionally
delivered through GPS.
We'll talk about
addresses, and we're
going to talk about places.
So I'm going to hand over to
Laurence to take you through.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thank you.
So latitude and longitude.
When we think about the
world that we live in,
every point on the
surface of this sphere
called planet Earth
has a location.
There's a number
of different ways
that you can measure where
a point is on a sphere,
but the most common in our
world is latitude and longitude.
And so when you're doing
latitude and longitude,
then you can know exactly
where that point is
on the surface of the
sphere, and there's a system
called GPS in order to do that.
Most of us have phones with
a built-in GPS on them,
and being able to
access that GPS,
being able to program against
that GPS, is pretty easy.
It's pretty straightforward.
So if you're using
Android as an example,
Android has a thing called
a Fused Location Provider.
And what the Fused
Location Provider does
is it brings in a number of
signals from different places--
from GPS, from network signals,
from sniffing networks.
If you were at my
session earlier on,
you saw I had a little
robot that was doing that.
From beacons, cell towers, geo
fences, lots of other things
like that.
Lots of other sensors that
it fuses all of this together
to give you the best estimate
of where you are, and GPS
is one of the signals into that.
If you're an iOS developer,
the core location APIs
do the same thing.
They allow you to access
the GPS on the phone
so that you can get a
sense of where you are,
latitude and longitude wise.
But as Ankur mentioned, you
don't always see the GPS.
You might be
indoors, or you might
live in a big city like New
York City, where the canyon
effect of the
skyscrapers can block
your access to the satellite
so that you can't get
a good read on where you are.
So other signals, such
as beacons and Wi-Fi
and all that kind of
thing are available.
So you can get your
latitude and longitude,
and you can see as
accurately as possible
where you are on the surface
of the planet at this moment
in time.
Now, for programming, on
Android it's very, very simple
on the Fused Location Provider.
It fires an event called
onLocationChanged.
And onLocationChanged has
an object called location.
And guess what?
Two the properties of this
are latitude and longitude
that you can get by calling the
getLatitude and getLongitude
methods.
So pretty easy if you're
an Android developer
to be able to get the lat-long
of your current location
or of your device's
current location.
Similar as an iOS developer,
the CL Location Manager,
which is part of core
location, gives you back,
and you can set it
for desired accuracy,
for example, the nearest
10 meters, I think.
That's pretty accurate, right?
And then what you do is
you can start monitoring it
for significant changes,
which I really like how
they've done this in the API.
So what that means is that
if I've set it for 10 meter,
then a significant change
is something of 10 meters
or above, and then it will
fire an event back to me.
Because GPS can be very
expensive battery-wise,
heat-wise, for you to
actually use on your phone,
so something like those
significant changes
will fire that event.
And then out of the
location manager,
you can read the
latitude and longitude.
So again, you can
get the point where
you are on this planet
with reasonable accuracy.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Laurence, if I
had a internet of things device,
and I was to stick it on a
robot to go and get location,
how do you think I might
be able to do that?
LAURENCE MORONEY: You
mean something like this?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah,
something exactly like this.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I bet you
wouldn't give it a nice bow
tie like this guy has.
So if you were to
stick one on there--
I can't start them up now.
How would you do that,
and how would you
be able to find his location,
given that he might be indoors,
given that he doesn't have
GPS, or something like that?
Well, how you can do that is you
can sense the world around you
for Wi-Fi access points or
for cell tower access points.
And when you sense these,
like, we all have a laptop.
We open up our laptop,
we look for Wi-Fi.
You drop down the thing, and
you see the access points,
and you see signal strength.
It's because the operating
system gives you a service that
allows you to do that.
In Linux, there's
a WLAN zero scan
command that you
can use to get that,
and Mac you have a
command for doing it,
and Windows, you have
a command in Android,
and iOS you have a
command for doing it.
And what that will do
is it will give you
a list of access points and
the actual relative signal
strength at that access point.
Now, if you're
doing that, then you
can start doing interesting
stuff to triangulate it
because there is a
formula that if you know
the strength of the signal
from an access point,
and you know the frequency
on which that access
point broadcasts, like 2.4
gigahertz or 5 gigahertz,
you can actually calculate the
estimated distance between you
and that access point.
There's a few things
that can throw it off,
for example, 2.4
gigahertz wireless.
The signal in a 2.4
gigahertz wireless
tends to get absorbed
by water, so if there's
a lot of water between
you and the target,
then you get a lot
of loss in strength.
So I always say, my
pro tip as a Googler,
if you take nothing away
from this conference,
if you want to increase the
power of your Wi-Fi at home,
if you're using 2.4 gigahertz,
just ask your family
to lie down, and then you'll
get a much stronger signal,
because the water in
their body isn't going
to be blocking the signal.
It works every time.
I've tried it.
No I haven't.
So anyway, how this works is you
scan for Wi-Fi access points,
and then using the formula
that you can calculate upon,
it will then give you the
estimated distance between you
and that access point.
Now, if you have that
estimated distance,
that gives you a
radius of a circle.
It can't tell you
where the access
point is because you don't
know what direction it's
coming from.
But you know there's
an access point there.
You know you're a
distance from it.
So from there, you
can draw a circle.
So if you have a
second access point,
you can draw another circle.
And if you have a
third access point,
you can draw another circle.
So the more access points
you're able to scan,
and the more accurate
the signal you're
able to read or the
signal loss off of these
you're able to
read, then you can
start plotting these circles.
And the overlap of the circles
is where you're likely to be.
So at Google, we actually
have a geolocation API
that does all the heavy
lifting of this for you.
So if you were to scan
your local Wi-Fi access
points, and that's what
this little robot does
that Ankor was asking about.
So that will scan the
local Wi-Fi access points.
It will get their IDs
that identify them.
It will get the signal
loss off of them.
It will call--
it'll pass that up
to Google with a
simple HTTP call,
so it's one of our
web service APIs.
And then the web
service will then
return a pretty
good guess of where
you are latitude
and longitude wise,
as well as an accuracy
estimation around that.
If you remember that red
circle on my previous diagram,
it was a circle,
it wasn't a point.
Because where all of these
circles for signal overlap,
it's going to give you
a space, and that space
is going to determine
roughly where you are.
So what you'll
get back from this
is expected latitude and
longitude, as well as
an accuracy estimation.
The most common
one I've seen when
I scan it in a
suburban neighborhood
is usually about 20 meters.
So it's pretty good,
I think, if I'm--
well, I drive this guy
around my neighborhood
when I was testing him.
And I was usually within 20
meters of my actual latitude
and longitude that I detected
using a GPS by doing this,
just by sniffing the Wi-Fi
signals in my neighborhood.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Now, this
is particularly good
if in your business, the type
of app that you're building
happens to do some
sort of asset tracking,
and you're in locations
where GPS can't be found.
And particularly, as
Laurence referred to earlier,
was the canyon effect.
So in certain cities
with tall buildings,
you do lose that
direct line of sight.
But in those urban
environments, there
are a lot of Wi-Fi access
points that are still
able to help us reliably locate
real time movement of whatever
asset it is that
you're tracking.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And with
Ankur's Australian accent,
I see the closed captioning
made it the Kenyan effect rather
than the canyon effect.
[LAUGHS] Just if anybody
is reading along.
So here's an example of
how you would use that API.
So here's where
I've done a scan.
I've gotten a couple
of Wi-Fi access points.
I see the signal
strength off of them.
When you scan for
Wi-Fi, all of the APIs
will give you back
a signal strength.
That's how your
phone knows when you
see the little visualization,
usually of three bars,
or your laptop knows you
get that visualization.
It's off of the signal strength.
A good signal strength
is between negative 30
and negative 60 decibels.
If you're below
negative 60, you're
going to start having drop outs.
If you're above negative 30,
it's probably lying to you.
And so you'll get a signal, or
you're sitting on top of it.
You'll get some data like this.
You'll create a
json file out of it.
You'll call the back end API,
and then the back end API
will return json like that
on the right hand side.
Just as an example, for a
device built using this,
I have this little guy
that I've been showing.
And this is a
little pet tracker.
And what this has,
instead of-- so
if you've got a tiny little
dog like I do, instead
of you needing a full GPS
circuit to be able to see where
your dog is at all times,
this guy has a 2G cell,
has Wi-Fi and has a BLE, so I
can find my dog wherever he is.
But unfortunately,
if he's lost now,
he's lost, because I
have it in my pocket.
So with that in mind,
you're able to have
all of these tools, from GPS
all the way down to, if there
is no GPS available,
to scan Wi-Fi,
to scan cell services,
to know where
you are on the
surface of the planet,
to get a latitude
and a longitude
with reasonable accuracy
for where you are.
And that's nice, and
that's all very good.
But we don't live in a
latitude and longitude, right?
We generally live in an address.
And when civilization
comes to an environment,
and infrastructure is
built and roads are built,
and houses are built, the way
of encoding, routing something
to a particular location
is through an address.
But addresses have existed
long before Google Maps.
And addresses have existed
long before computers and all
of these kind of things.
And as a result, there's all
of these wildly diverging
standards of address.
So I live in the Seattle area,
and we have these horrendously
complicated addresses.
But like everybody else in
the US, we have a zip code.
So if you're filling something
out, you get a zip code.
But I grew up in Ireland,
and I grew up in the UK,
and over there, we have
postcodes instead of zip codes.
And there's some encoding
in the postcodes as well.
Like, OK.
Trivia question.
My zip code used to
begin with the letter CF.
Can you guess what
city I lived in?
Not many British people here.
OK.
What?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: It was Cambridge.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
It was Cardiff.
So close, close.
Pretty good.
It was actually encoded
in the postcode.
And I think Australian
postcodes are different, right?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Australian
postcodes are different.
Again, if you look at--
so in America, it's a zip
code, which is fully numeric.
In the UK, it's
a postcode, which
you've got letters and numbers.
Australia decided to take
a little bit of both.
And so we have
postcodes like the UK,
but we have fully numeric
postcodes like the US.
So there is this inconsistency.
And if you're a business that
has to do global delivery,
you need to understand that
your user's address, you
need to have a good way of being
able to route whatever package
it is to them,
and be comfortable
that it's going to get there
on time rather than get lost.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
there's no letters
in the Australian postcode.
ANKUR KOTWAL: That is correct.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So what
does the postman deliver then
if you have no letters?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Move
on, Laurence, move on.
It didn't work during rehearsal,
I don't think it works now.
[LAUGHS]
LAURENCE MORONEY:
But from the point
of view as a software
developer, there's
a lot of complexity
in handling addresses.
Street names are
structured differently,
house numbers are
structured differently.
When I was growing
up in Ireland,
and I see American
addresses, where you've got
houses in the 35 thousands--
I couldn't understand how a
house could have number 35,000.
The biggest house number
we had was probably 99.
And so addresses are very
different all over the world.
It's very difficult
to get them right.
It's very easy for an end
user to get them wrong,
particularly if you're typing
on a phone, where you've
got a tiny little keyboard.
So tools to make a
software developer's life
who is building something where
people enter addresses easier
are paramount, and that's why we
have things such as the address
autocomplete in Google Maps.
So as you can see here
that somebody was typing in
Sydney Number 1 Marti, and in
Sydney, there's a Martin Place,
there's a Martin Avenue,
there's a Martin Street,
and there's a Martin
Street in Paddington,
and there's a 1 Martin Place.
So there's all of
these different things,
but just by typing
1 Marti, this person
is now given the ability
to pick from one of these.
And then when they
pick from one of them,
they know that the
address is going
to be formatted correctly.
And in this case, they're
all Australian addresses,
so the postcode probably doesn't
have any letters in them,
right?
And as a result, if
you're building a service,
or if you are building
an application that
needs to route parcels or
needs to route details of cars
or people or anything, then
this reduces the friction
of that greatly, as well
as greatly increasing
the user experience
because nobody
wants to build an
online shopping service,
and then you deliver
goods to the wrong people
because they haven't entered
the addresses correctly.
So how do you do this?
How do you build this?
So just a quick example
in an Android application.
So there's an address
order complete activity,
and there's an address
order complete fragment.
In this case, I'm just
showing the fragment.
Here there is a
fragment, and you just
give the fragment the name.
I've abbreviated in the code.
That's
com.google.android.gms.location
at the bottom, and then there
is the place autocomplete
fragment.
You define a fragment
such as this,
and then you use your fragment.
And when you use the fragment,
the autocomplete fragment,
upon the user having picked
something from that list
that I showed a moment ago,
the setOnPlaceSelectedListener
will fire the
onPlaceSelected event.
So that onPlaceSelected
event will
return an object called a place,
and that place object then
has all the metadata
that you need
associated with that address,
including the address.
But there's lots of other
good stuff that's in the place
that we're going to get
to in just a moment.
Actually, why don't we
get to it right now?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
So just to call out that auto
complete widget one more time,
it's available on the web,
it's available on Android,
and it's available on iOS.
And I hope the value
is really clear.
It's really simple to
use for a developer.
You get a reliable address
input that you can definitely
start routing your
deliveries to,
or whatever it is
that you need to do.
And from a user
standpoint, you've really
reduced that friction,
and you've effectively
increased confidence in
the service for both sides.
Really, really handy.
Now, here, this is a
picture of a theme park.
When we recall our visits
to our theme parks,
we think of Disneyland,
Universal Studios,
whichever theme park
it is that you went to.
Again, we don't think of
these places in addresses.
We don't think of them
even at a city level.
We think of them, actually,
as a semantic place.
And for that very purpose,
we built out the Places API.
Because if you remember
back to that graph
I showed you earlier of
location intelligence
and building it up, one
of the fundamental parts
of that is that we needed
to understand the world
as our users understood it.
We needed to build
a good understanding
of the urban environments, of
the way people would look up
addresses or establishments.
And so Places is a database,
a point of interest database
that we have that has
over 100 million places
all over the world.
And we use many mechanisms
to build this database out
and keep it current.
So let me show you a
quick couple of examples.
One of the ways that we're able
to build these Places database
out is just by looking
at satellite photos,
and we're able to identify
building outlines and roofs
and so on so that we can see
sort of where a place finishes
or exactly its
location on the planet
and delineate it
from the next one.
So satellite photos are one
way that we can do this.
Another way we could do
it is just through even
our consumer app, Google Maps.
So here, this is
Shoreline Amphitheater.
It's just behind the Google
Campus in Mountain View.
And what you are
starting to see here
is that we're actually editing.
We're able to suggest edits.
So we're able to have our users
provide us with information
if it happens to be
incomplete or inaccurate.
They can suggest a name;
they can suggest an address.
And there's some additional
metadata there as well.
People have rated the place.
This is the kind of
location intelligence
we're talking about.
There's ratings, there's photos,
you can go to Street View,
so on and so forth.
We of course have the
underlying metadata
that we need from our latitude
and longitude standpoint,
but what I want to
really highlight
is that we have very user
visible and user relevant
information there.
So suggesting edits
through Google Maps
is another way that we're able
to gather some of this data.
We also have an API call
the Google My Business API.
So if you have a
business, one way
to get it listed onto Google
Maps is to use this API.
And it's particularly
useful when
you've got lots of storefronts.
And so basically, you
can go in, and you
can provide all of this
data and keep it current.
And it's, of course,
every business,
it's in their best
interest to do so.
We also rely on Google
Search to provide us
some of this information.
So Google Search does a really
good job of indexing storefront
websites to make sure that
things like opening hours
are current.
And for those of you
that might think,
how often do opening
hours change,
it's actually quite frequently.
Think about all of the
public holidays that happen,
when stores are closed.
Holiday season, when stores tend
to be open for longer hours,
so people can do their
holiday shopping.
This is the kind of information
that does change from time
to time.
And the Places API is a great
way to get that information.
So once we have this
Places database,
the way that we're
able to surface it
is through the Google
Maps app or website
and through the Places API.
Because we want to
make this information
available to developers so
that you can build innovative
apps on top of it.
Now, the Places API, it really
aims to answer three things,
or help with three things.
One is to help
your users realize
where they are, to locate them.
And if you look at
this whole talk,
so far, we've been talking
very much about locations.
Because when a user thinks
about where are they,
they're not looking for
a latitude, longitude.
They're not looking for
an address, in most cases.
They are literally looking
for the establishment.
They also want to be able to
tell what is at that place,
so it's great for doing some
discovery ahead of time,
but also discovery
around them, around
that particular location.
The thing that ties places
together is this thing.
It's called the place ID.
Every single place in the
world has a unique place ID.
And place IDs are
not just unique,
but they're stable,
so they don't change.
And if for whatever
reason, a business
happens to close
down or move, we're
able to take that
developer experience
and keep it actually
really strong.
So if a business wants
to move locations,
we will still
return your results
for the new place based
on its old place ID,
and we'll give you an
updated place ID as well.
And of course, with
Places, the other advantage
is that it has global coverage.
And when we think of a place,
it's any number of things.
Right?
It could be something as simple
as road segments, an address,
or even shops.
So cafes, bars, libraries,
schools, places of worship.
In fact, in Moscone
Center, we're
able to even tell you
the difference in places
between level two
and level three.
And you can start to see some
really interesting use cases.
Places help us solve that
indoor mapping problem, right?
Because with indoor
mapping, you don't
have GPS to rely on, so you
get a very inaccurate latitude,
longitude.
Even addresses are
somewhat limited
when you're talking
about indoor mapping,
because you might have
the address for the mall
that you're at rather
than a particular cafe
that you happen to
be within that mall.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
then some addresses
can have different layers
encoded in the address.
Like there's 221B
Baker Street, which
we're all familiar with, right?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Who knows
what 221B Baker Street is?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, good.
ANKUR KOTWAL: A few people.
Great.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yes.
But that's just an example.
Like, if you have an
apartment split in two,
like 221 Baker Street
and 221B Baker Street,
221B is very famous, but 221
isn't quite so famous, right?
So with the ability
to be able to separate
into unique locations like
that, then the address of 221B
would be considered a separate
location, a separate place.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So
full disclosure,
I didn't know what
it was, and we
are going to find out,
because Laurence is
going to tell us in a minute.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I tried to
get the hat, but I couldn't.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Location sharing
is also a very important action
that users take, right?
It happens a lot more often
than you might realize.
If you think about your
day to day conversations
with your friends or your
family, you could be saying,
hey, where are you?
I'm here.
Are you running late?
Yes, I'm stuck in
traffic at this point,
or this particular
train is running late,
I'm at this station.
And location sharing is
also one of those things--
as a developer, it's not
always easy to get right.
Because as I said,
there's different sources
of information that
you can rely on,
and just providing a latitude,
longitude or an address
isn't enough.
Places, however, are
a much better way
to actually share your location.
Because again, it's
a semantic place.
It's how we naturally
think of our location.
So what you're seeing
here is actually
our place picker, which
is a UI widget that is
available on Android and iOS.
And what it does is when you
go to share your location,
if you present the
place picker, it
shows you a nice map with a
bunch of places around you.
Because you're using
indoor mapping,
we give you a list of
locations that you could be at,
and we sort that list
based on the likelihood
that you are actually
at that place.
And the example where that
becomes very important,
the sort order of that
list, is that we're
able to apply some of this
location intelligence.
If you're at a bus stop that
happens to be close to a cafe,
but you're at that
bus stop at 6:00 PM,
and that cafe closed at
5:00 PM, it's unlikely
that you're in that cafe.
And so we're able
to dynamically sort
that list in our place picker,
the likelihood of places
that you're at.
We can change that likelihood
based on real world
information in real time.
Now, I just showed
you the place picker,
which is a drop-in element.
But if you wanted to go ahead
and get the place yourself
programmatically,
like, basically
show no user interface,
here's some Android code
on how you would do that.
At the top, you can see that
we call this method, called
getCurrentPlace, and it's part
of the place detection API
namespace.
We also have a call
back method in this,
so it's an asynchronous call.
But when it goes ahead
and returns those places,
it gives us this buffer.
It's a list of likely
places, and they're
sorted in likelihood order.
And because it's this place
object, we can just look at it
and get the likelihood.
We can get its name, and most
importantly, we can get its ID.
The place ID is really,
really important
because it helps us
retrieve this place again
when we need to.
So one thing I want to
make clear about places
is if you use places in your
apps, hold on to the place ID.
Don't hold on to the
other details that
come on with the
rest of the place--
the name, the opening hours,
the address, because that's
information that could
change over time.
We also have some
terms of service,
because we want to make
sure that that data remains
fresh in your apps.
So the thing you
want to hold on to,
the thing you want
to cache, or--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cache.
Like the rest of us.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Is the
place ID, because it
means that you have
that one point,
that primary key
that you need to be
able to resolve to whichever
place you want in a future
look up.
And we've just told
you three things.
We talked about lat-long,
we've talked about addresses,
we've talked about places.
Laurence is now
going to tell you how
we can bring this all together.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sure, so I
like to think about it as a--
ANKUR KOTWAL: Oh, sorry.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You forgot.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Oh, I missed it.
My bad.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So excited
to get me back on stage.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I'm so excited
to get you back on stage.
I'm going to give you a
little bit more about places,
and that is the
kind of information
that you can get about places.
So once you have that place
ID, and you return to a place,
see this information
you see here
from Google Maps, the
actual consumer app?
This is the same
type of information
that you can use
in your own apps
with the place object itself.
So we have the name, we have the
address, website, phone number,
so on.
But we also have ratings.
Right?
We have photos that
you can bring in,
so that when you want to
present a place to your users,
you can show it in
a rich, visual way.
It doesn't have to be on a map.
You can even present the place
type that this place is at.
So if you don't want
to present bars,
for example, if it's an app
that's targeted for a younger
audience, or a bar
just happens to be
an inappropriate type of
place you want to show,
you can just not present that.
And then for users that are
doing that sort of discovery,
price level is really
important because you
can get into a situation
where users are looking
for a restaurant,
and they're looking
for something that meets
their needs in a better way.
When you hold on
to a place ID, you
can return that place object
by calling a method called
get place by ID.
And so what we do here is,
again it's an asynchronous call.
But when we get that call
back, the on result call back,
the first thing
we're doing is just
validating that we
got a place back.
And the only time when
you won't get a place back
is if you pasted an invalid
place ID, for example.
But we go and validate that we
got a place back for our ID.
And then once we have
that place object,
we can do all sorts
of things with it.
Like I said, we have
the name, the address,
and all of this metadata
around that place.
It's immensely powerful.
But the place ID
happens to be the key
that you want to hold on
to to use the Places API.
Now I'll definitely
give it to you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thank you.
So again, thinking
in terms of there's
all of these separate concepts.
There's latitude and
longitude for plotting
where you are on the
surface of the globe,
there's addresses for routing
to where your house is, there's
places, and in this case, it's
a unique and distinct Google
thing, where we have an ID
associated with a place,
and we have all the metadata
associated with that place.
How do we make all of
this work together?
And we like to think about
this in terms of a stack.
We're developers,
engineers, after all.
Ultimately,
everything's a stack.
So starting with the
surface of the planet
and all those
points on it, those
determined to get
some intelligence
about those points, you
need the coordinates.
You need to know
where that point is.
You need your latitude
and your longitude.
And as a result, we've
got a bunch of APIs
for that, as I
showed earlier on.
Within the operating
system level itself,
you've got things like fused
location provider in Android
or core location in iOS.
But then on top of this to be
able to get some intelligence,
like things like the
geolocation APIs,
so that if you can't
get a GPS signal,
we have a service that you'll be
able to determine where you are
as a location on the planet.
Then when it comes to addresses,
so that the next step up,
once civilization has
reached that location,
addresses become important.
And we want to give you some
tools that will make it easier
for you to be able to use
addresses in your application,
so that you get the right
address with a great user
experience, instead of
doing lots of typing,
and you reduce errors.
And that's what the
autocomplete API was all about.
And then, as Ankur
mentioned, places.
And places, for me, is when it
really begins to get exciting.
Because I want to know about
the world around me, and it's
hard for me to know
about the world around me
by looking at the numbers
of a latitude or longitude
or looking at address.
Sometimes the address
has a famous implication.
221B Baker Street, I go, OK.
I can get excited about that.
But if it's 123 Letsy Avenue,
I have no idea what that means.
And as a result then,
there's place metadata
that's built on top of this.
So with the place
metadata, I can now
start seeing things such
as reviews, prices, photos,
and all of these things.
And then once I have all of
this data-- and this place
ID is the thing that
ties it all together--
then there's a bunch
of other services
that I can start using,
such as the Directions API.
So if I know a place
that I want to go to,
and if I know where I am,
then I can get directions
to go to where I want to go.
And I can get turn
by turn directions.
I can get them by
transit, I can get it
by walking, by
biking, by driving,
and all that kind of stuff.
So I wanted to come up
with an idea for a scenario
where I would bring
all of these together.
So have you ever
traveled to a city,
and you knew there was something
you wanted to see in that city,
but you only had the smallest
piece of information about it?
And you might go up to the
hotel concierge and go,
is there a cafe called
Speedy's around here somewhere?
And the concierge
would have no idea,
because you just have that
tiny, tiny piece of information.
So I thought, what if you
could build a service that
builds upon all of this
location intelligence
to be able to discover
things like that for you,
like a digital
concierge, as it were?
So I'm going to step through
how the APIs could do that.
So you've probably
established by now
that I'm a huge fan
of Sherlock Holmes,
and that's where 221B
Baker Street comes from.
And any of you watch the
modern BBC version of Sherlock?
Isn't it brilliant?
OK.
Now, I travel to London
once or twice a year,
and most of "Sherlock"
is filmed in Cardiff,
where I used to live.
But when I last
traveled to London,
it was about two years ago.
I was in London,
and I really wanted
to know where they filmed
the scenes of 221B Baker
Street because they didn't
film them on Baker Street.
Because I know the area, and
that's not where they filmed.
So I was thinking through.
It's like, how
could I figure out
where these scenes are filmed,
so that I can go and visit it,
and I can geek out.
So let me give an
example of that.
So if we switch to the laptop.
OK.
So say I'm staying in a
hotel in downtown London,
and I've watched
episodes of "Sherlock,"
and I know where they film
it, there's a cafe next door.
And there's a very distinctive
cafe, and it's called Speedy's.
So whenever you're watching
an episode of the TV show,
and you see, as they're coming
in and out of the house,
you'll see Speedy's Cafe.
And that's the only
piece of intelligence
I have about where this
might actually be filmed.
So using the nearby
search API, what I can do
is I know my latitude
and longitude
of where I am right now.
And I say, OK.
Can I search for a place
in London within 10 miles
of my latitude and
longitude, called Speedy's.
So I did this search, based
on the hotel that I usually
stay in.
And it came up, and
it found two places.
So if I scroll down, and I
take a look, it's kind of--
sorry if it's hard to see.
But one of them was called
Speedy Sandwich Bar and Cafe,
and one of them was
called Speedy Noodle.
OK.
So now, I don't think
Mycroft and Sherlock are
noodle kind of
guys, so I figured
that it must be Speedy's
Sandwich and Cafe.
So I thought, OK.
So if I was building
an application
to do this kind
of thing, then it
would give me Speedy
Sandwich Bar and Cafe,
and that has a place
ID associated with it.
And it also has map
attributes and all those kinds
of things associated with it.
So I could call
the place details
for the place ID
for Speedy's Cafe.
And then in this
place details, I
get a whole bunch of rich
information coming back
about it.
And I'm like, but say if I
was building this service,
that somebody is trying
to find something,
he says, all he knows is that
it's called Speedy's Cafe.
Wouldn't it be cool that it
says, I think I've found it.
Let me give you some
pictures so you can verify.
So a call to the
place details API
would give me back
something like this.
It would give me
back a map reference.
And on the map
reference, it also
gives me back some pictures.
And here, these
pictures, this was
you URI that was
embedded within that json
that I just showed you.
These pictures then show me this
picture of this Speedy's Cafe.
And this was one of
our local explorers,
called Eleanora, who took this
picture and uploaded it to it.
And if you've ever watched the
show, does this look like it?
Does this look
like the location?
It does, right?
And you can-- there's
even other photographs,
and you can see inside.
And if you look closely, you
can see where they filmed.
And as you keep
going around here,
you can start geeking out.
You can see Sherlock
getting out of his car,
right beside Speedy's Cafe.
So yes, I found the location.
All I knew was that it
was filmed at a location,
and it was a
Speedy's Cafe there.
And now I can go on, I can geek
out, and I can go to the cafe
where Sherlock and
Mycroft and Moriarty
drink tea and plan on
conquering the world.
But wait a minute,
is it open now?
Well, guess what?
The place details will tell
me if it's open now or not.
So again, if I go into
the place details,
we'll see that there's a--
first of all, there's
a flag that says,
open now equals true,
that's a dead giveaway.
But otherwise, it also
tells me the opening hours.
As you can see, as I
scroll through this json,
on any particular day,
it tells me when it opens
and when it closes.
So this is great.
I know that this is the
location of Speedy's Cafe.
I know that it's open now.
I know I can go and hang out
with Sherlock and the boys.
Well, how do I get there?
All right.
Well, I'm in London.
I don't have a car, so I'm
relying on public transport.
So there's yet another API,
called the directions API.
And if you look really
closely at the URI here--
I know it's a little bit small--
but when I started,
I was in a hotel.
I used my GPS, and I got my
latitude and my longitude.
But when I did all
this searching,
and I matched against these
pictures, and I got a cafe,
I got a place ID, and it was
the place ID of that cafe.
So if you look at the
URI, in my origin,
I'm giving a latitude
and longitude
because that's what I starting
with, and at my destination,
I'm giving a place ID.
So I can call the API,
and I get details back.
And I say to the API,
well, I'm not in a car.
I'm in London,
can I use transit?
And then what it'll do
is it will come back,
and out of my hotel, it'll
even tell me where I step out--
where are we?
It will tell me
the arrival time.
Like in this case,
when I was calling it,
by the time I arrived
there, it was 3:35.
So I could check that
against the closing time
to see if I could make it.
But then it would also
tell me step by step.
Walk out of my hotel, turn left.
Walk to Green Park Station.
It's 0.4 of a kilometer.
It will take me six minutes.
When I'm in Green
Park Station, then it
will tell me which
Tube lane to get onto.
The Tube is the London
Underground, the subway.
So it will tell me
which one to get on,
and it will tell me
where to get off.
And then once I'm--
so here, I get on it,
on the subway towards
Walthamstow Central Station,
which is-- if you know London,
the lines are arranged by color
and name, but also
endpoint of the line.
Walthamstow Central is the
endpoint of one of the lines.
It will tell me
which one to get on,
it will tell me
which one to get off.
And then once I'm
off, how far I have
to walk to get to that cafe.
So if I were building a
service like this one,
by tying all of this
type of information
together, by finding
places, by place details,
by navigation, by routing,
and all of that kind of stuff,
that one piece of
information, the place ID,
is what allowed me to
tie it all together.
So I could go, and
I could geek out,
and I could eat where Sherlock
eats, and that kind of stuff.
So I was trying
to think of a name
for if I had to build
a service like this,
and I came up with the name
"Elementary, My Dear Ankur."
Sorry.
You said they would
laugh at that one.
ANKUR KOTWAL: No, I did not.
LAURENCE MORONEY: [LAUGHS].
Can we switch back to
the slides, please?
So that's, again, if
we think about all
of these attributes that
are available to you, all
these geographic attributes,
from latitudes and longitudes
to addresses to places
to metadata about places,
that if you use the
intelligence of the place
ID to bring all
of these together,
you can walk up
and down the stack,
and you can build scenarios
like I just mentioned there.
And with that, if you're
watching any of these videos
on YouTube, if you've watched
any of the other sessions,
that's really what we're
trying to strive towards
to make your life a
lot easier in building
geo-aware applications, so that
you folks will be the ones who
are building the new scenarios.
Like Ankur mentioned a few
scenarios earlier on that
weren't-- we didn't even
hear of them 12 months ago.
And I'm really excited to
see the things that we're
going to be talking
about in 12 months' time
that people have done because
they're navigating the stack,
that they're building
things with this geostack.
And I would love to hear
what you're going to do.
And any wrapping
up words from Ankur
before we have any questions?
ANKUR KOTWAL: No.
I was going to open
it up to questions.
Thank you very much.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]